let's try drew from fort lauderdale drew
you're on the air
david sir oh you're perfectly clear
yes can you hear me nice i can hear you
fine
okay great
what's going on if rittenhouse is found
not guilty on all murder charges yes
what do you think the potential uh
backlash or reaction
to the public will be
um i want to be really careful because i
don't wanna
encourage any violence but i think there
is a possibility of violence after the
verdict no matter what the verdict is
yes i mean i think regardless of what
happens uh it will only further divide
and agitate us as a country i mean
i um
i i worry that that's the case i worry
that that's the case and i hope that
that doesn't happen
the other thing i worry about is i
believe rittenhouse is uh going to be
the next mega senator
right yeah no no whoever he ends up in
this guy is going to be lionized and
made a hero if he's found guilty he will
be made a martyr the right is just
foaming for a sort of zimmerman like
character and i think to be perfectly
frank i think rittenhouse is more
sympathetic than zimmerman was
absolutely yeah absolutely and uh also
is the judge's last name schroeder yes
is that any relation to ricky schroeder
i have no idea who that is
ricky schroeder is uh the silver spoons
kid
uh the actor who who was helping written
house
uh immediately after this this all
happened oh i wasn't paying much
attention at that time that's
interesting i i can't imagine there's a
relation
i just i just was yeah i thought that
was strange it but yes i don't know
anything about it
thank you for uh the time sir pleasure
appreciate the call very very much